…can we do more on the economy though?
Modi's biggest achievement in the last two years
has been the real uptick in a foreign direct
investment coming into India. India has, for
the first time, overtaken China in terms of
greenfield direct investment. This is essentially
people investing in new factories and new
projects in India.
The biggest disappointment is among those
who thought that Modi would put in place deep
structural reforms. We're talking about things
like reforming India's labor laws. We're talking
about reforming the way land is acquired for
industry and infrastructure.
We're talking about privatization of loss-making
companies. And in all of these cases, Modi
has either moved too slowly, or he's been
stymied in the upper house of parliament,
or he's kicked these reforms to the state.
The biggest challenge he faces is the creation
of jobs. He's going to be up for reelection
in 2019, and India needs to create 12 million
new jobs a year just to stay standing still
in place.
How would you rate Modi's economic performance
over the last two years? Let us know your
thoughts in the comments below, and also let
us know if there any other topics that you
would like AEI scholars to look at in 60 seconds.